so you want to watch me golf in a little
mermaid costume and not just any little
mermaid costume one that i think might
be made for an eight-year-old let me
know in the comments what you guys think
of my golfing skills i'm pretty sure
there's a small chance i could become a
professional golfer when you're done
checking out my sweet golfing mermaid
skills just click that annotation right
up there and you can choose a new
adventure what are you doing there miss
golfer hey
i'm just hitching up my clubs and then
put this outfit
um
i don't even know which club to use i
don't know
the big one this one's big right you
look really nice in this rainbow in the
backdrop though so here we are this is
uh number one
bring the club back further there you go
there you go
it was like way over there
it wasn't straight at all but yeah but i
don't know i've never had a golf ball
before in my life did you see that
it went now we have to find it
how do you feel about that first tee off
dude i feel like a professional i don't
know how to do this
robert
robert baby this one's for you
all right so some nice people told me
the uh how the clubs work
so the lower
the lower the number the farther the
ball goes uh the higher the number the
closer you want to be to the hole
miss that memo
all right get your ball what color
you're gonna use this time
oh i forgot i'm supposed to say four
what about four four five
that was a really good shot
that was really good i don't like my own
horn or anything
like that's actually a really good
shot
because that was hole seven but
apparently i was shooting the whole two
which is 580 yards away
so maybe this whole one
i just don't know we'll check the tapes
is it bad
here we go this is whole it's not gonna
matter
seaweed is always greener and somebody
else's lake you're dreaming about going
up there but that is a big mistake i
don't think you're supposed to use a tee
anymore he doesn't think so either cause
that's coming off
yeah
i'm playing how you're supposed to play
do it again
that's a good word
that's okay that's okay yeah you guys
are almost out
i couldn't believe what i just saw
apparently you're not allowed to drive
on the tee boxes you know what if i knew
what a t-box was i wouldn't have drove
on it jump one i did i learned i'm a
really bad golfer
i think the ball's gone